even before Kia storm had asked his
first question Rishi sunak managed to
slip in a dig about Labor's position on
gender it was in response to this given
that the leader of the opposition
apparently doesn't know what a woman is
but he won't stand up to defend women in
his own party for voicing views on
[Applause]
zombies in charge as DPP does my right
honorable friend think that the labor
party are in any position to teach
anyone about respect for women they
should work out the answer to one very
simple question I'm certain what a woman
is is he
[Applause]
the labor leader did not take the bait
and dodged that topic today kiestama
could have asked about the Sudan
evacuation or the Dominic Rob bullying
Rao but instead he focused on the
economy and cost of living with some
thinly veiled attacks on the PM
including a repost to last week being
labeled Mr Softee
this is Mr 24 tax Rises
and I've never heard anything so out of
touch does he really think that
everything's fine or is he just clueless
about life outside of his bubble he
refuses to scrap the non-dom status that
benefits him and his family
that's prime minister is so removed from
the country that he both
know a single working-class person
those questions from secure did seem
shorter and sharper than usual but it
all got pretty personal whilst armor
painted sunak as out of touch sumac
argued stammer is weak he talks about
this London thing I think he's already
spent the money that he claims he's
raised on five different things but
run day in the other place they decided
to side with extremist protesters
[Applause]
because that's what the conservative
government does
perhaps no surprise we saw that tone of
debate with local elections now just
eight days away and meanwhile the snp's
leader made an effective point with
questions about UK immigration policy
can I ask the prime minister to outline
the safe and Legal Group available to a
child Refugee seeking to flee Sudan and
come to the United Kingdom now that he
has confirmed that there is no safe and
legal route well he therefore confirm
that it would be his government's
intention to detain and Deport a child
Refugee who flees Sudan and comes to the
United Kingdom this country has a proud
record of compassionately supporting
those who need our assistance elsewhere
the PM gave a clear answer on paying
reparations for the UK's role in slavery
offer a full and meaningful apology for
our country's role in slavery and
colonialism and commit to reparatory
Justice no no Mr Speaker when asked by
an smpmp about Dominic Robb and bullying
Mr sunac nodded towards the ongoing
police investigation into SMP finances
it is so old to be getting lectures on
values right now from the SNP
and the speaker got a little confused
introducing kierstama as if he was
running the country so just be aware
that somebody will be going for that cup
of tea today prime minister
that perhaps if opinion polls prove
accurate a sign of things to come